getting out in transition later done a
good job of value in the basketball but
not on that last play still trying to
promote the tough juice I'll go with
this one you can handle the
we
for the Celtics
[Applause]
[Music]
the liquors right there personal foul
for the Lakers tights not happy about
being picked up and Brad Stevens not
happy about transition defense there's
not comfortable getting close enough to
Kuzma to take away that three-point shot
and it doesn't make a difference
the left side very decisive he's looking
to put that thing up there smart able to
switch that screen so Kuzma taking
advance
basket against a very good defender and
Mark is smart and finding Larry man's to
block pass by smart and Jalen bow hunter
maybe a little bit too hard rattles off
three good
[Applause]
the opportunities for transition
this too may 3 bottles website maybe the
hamper oh you've got maybe bangs on the
need goes back so they got it there
quick
[Applause]
we bow Kuzma who else
that's the day when you go small